[Music]
tell your children
[Applause]
not to do
[Music]
[Applause]
in the house
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
be a macho
Oh
ow
[Music]
go
macho ass
[Music]
I
so bad
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald J Trump
[Music]
-
god
[Music]
from the leaves of Minnesota
to the hair
Tennessee
[Music]
see the shine
from Detroit down to
to
[Music]
every American part and his time we
it's a
[Music]
American
god
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much and hello Las
Vegas great to be with you they have a
big election tomorrow we've already won
the state I like cars better we just
take it just a kid we want I like it
that better you know the they say
they're gonna have a lot of problems
tomorrow I hate to tell you this I don't
know
have you heard I hear their computers
are all messed up just like they were in
Iowa they're not gonna be able to count
their vote they're going to tell you
about health care they're going to tell
you about our military and the jet
fighters and missiles and rockets but
they can't count votes they just can't
count they can't count votes but they're
saying they may not be able to do it
again they're still trying to tell us I
called up yesterday how're they doing in
Iowa was that two weeks ago they say
we're getting close that I get it close
they'll never know they'll never know
but I hear the same thing could happen
or I hope it doesn't actually I hope it
doesn't but I'm delighted to be back in
the state I love i have a beautiful
building right down the road
with the proud hard-working Patriots of
Nevada you're gonna say Nevada you say
that wrong you got problems you say
Nevada they go what now gotta be Nevada
[Applause]
with your help this November we're going
to defeat the radical socialist
Democrats and we are going to win Nevada
in a big beautiful land sighs now we
have some special people here you know
the special people are all of you that's
who the special but we have some very
special people and we celebrate one of
the greatest moments in the history of
sports some people say it was the single
greatest moment in the history of sports
it was called The Miracle on Ice do you
remember that that was when the Russians
had a team assembled that was probably
they say maybe the greatest team ever
assembled they were unbelievable and you
know our guys played a practice game
with them was it like a couple of weeks
before and I hate to tell you the score
was 10 to 3 and the USA was not on top
and this team was an incredible team and
they went in and it was amazing but
tomorrow marks the 40 years since the
United States men's hockey team defeated
then Soviet Union team in the 1980
Olympics
incredible that was incredible most of
you remember that looking at we got a
lot of young ones but we got a lot of
people that remember that and by the way
we got the Olympics coming back or kill
me to Los Angeles thank you thank you
president Trump thank you presidential
thank you very much thank you president
Trump
eight years eight years 2028 dead you
know what
unless I'm still president then which is
a distinct possible I won't be here and
you know what they'll do I'll say how's
the Olympics going
does anybody have a ticket for the
president that got the Olympics to come
here they'll say I want to thank and
they'll thank hundreds of people but
they won't thank you president that I'm
the one that pulled it off but that's
okay 2028 Olympics is coming to Los
Angeles it's going to be great
and we worked with the mayor of Los
Angeles he was great he called up and we
gave him a lot of help
I was president-elect then because the
president didn't want to get involved he
didn't want to get involved in getting
the Olympics so they called me and I was
president-elect hadn't taken office and
I got involved and I'll tell you they
were happy we got involved it was great
it's going to be very exciting today we
are thrilled to have with us 14 players
of that really incredible gold medal
team give him a big hand
and they were amazed they said boy it is
the big crowd I said it's only because
you guys are coming you know this thing
was supposed to be for this evening and
I said let me get back to Washington do
it early so we gave you almost no notice
you have thousands of people outside
thousands of people inside you had a
scene we're in Iowa we were in New
Hampshire you saw what happened in
Colorado less that was unbelievable
every place we go it's the same it's
been incredible I don't know if you saw
in the pictures last night of the
outside in Colorado it was incredible it
was you could have filled that arena up
four times and it was a big arena and
it's something so I hated to do it to
your 12 o'clock but I said let's go I
want to get back we got a deal with
China we got a deal with Russia we got a
deal with North Korea South Korea we got
a deal with the rest of the world get my
people back we got to get the hell out
of here right but we have a lot of time
I'd like down to invite these incredible
sport legends to join me on stage a
friend of mine and a very good golfer by
the way captain Mike erode hey bike Mike
where's Mike where is it Mike
[Applause]
you know who is he's a he's a fake
handicappers what do you say something
just welcome everybody ironic we happen
to be here to celebrate our 40th
anniversary the Vegas nights flew the
whole team out to honor us tonight and
for the weekend and we obviously thank
the people of Las Vegas for having us
here and we're looking forward to
celebrating a special time and it's a
great honor for the president to invite
us to be part of this event as well so
Vegas thanks for having us but just tell
them am i a good athlete and am i a good
golfer you are yes sir whatever you say
thanks Mike
that was some goaltending right how many
did you rebuff I mean but how many did
you very few but a lot of shots he was
like a pinata
so Mike that was great goaltender Jim
Craig so Jim rebuff to come here Jim
great goaltender great goal today they
didn't know what was happening they kept
shooting he doesn't know how many you
rebuffed how many did you rebuff 37
so let me ask was that as goaltender cuz
that was incredible
was that the greatest game you ever
played you've had a lot of great games
what was that the greatest game you've
ever played I was slightly important 37
[Applause]
bill Baker bill come up bill bank Dave
Christian Ken Morrow Jack O'Callahan
Mike Ramsay those legs took a beating
mark wells Neil Broughton John
Harrington Rob McClanahan buzz Schneider
Dave silk phil verchota and a great
coach and assistant coach at the time
Craig Patrick
[Applause]
they said four more years 12 more years
left for them
look it up look at the press look a Mike
look at the fake news back there it's a
lot
I always say
[Applause]
I always say that's like the Academy
Awards used to be this year we had a
movie they said best movie they
announced a movie from South Korea so
what's that all about look I get a
little great with South Korea but you
know I never saw that one before
they used to go best foreign movie now
we do it that way I don't get it but
that's what it used to be and this is
really an incredible time I'll tell you
what for our country that's why I like
to see things that we do get honored
because nobody is doing what we do
nobody can do it like us with the
greatest country in the world again we
have the greatest people we have the
greatest military by far we've totally
rebuilt our military jobs are booming
incomes are surging poverty is
plummeting factories are returning
confidence is soaring like these guys
the confidence is sorry
but you know we do have somebody that
I'd like to point out because this team
is been a coach and that Coach was a
very inspirational and I'd like to have
maybe one of you come up and just say a
few words about coach Brooks because he
was very very he was really a big he was
a big heart from this team please I
think it would be appropriate if you got
a few minutes that Herb Brooks his
daughter Kelly he's here representing
her father
[Applause]
and I can honestly tell you that Kelly
was not ready for this at all you got it
her her dad was an amazing coach she was
a great teacher he was a great motivator
at times maybe too much of a motivator
he was very demanding he was very
difficult to play for but trust me on
one thing there never once was a day
that we didn't respect the man and never
once was a day that we didn't trust him
and what he was trying to do he
orchestrated the greatest sports moment
of the 20th century and the guys behind
me I was so proud and honored to have
been a part of him and what he was able
to put together it was a perfect
environment a perfect storm sometimes
not only a great coach but great players
and great people that stand behind me
now so if Kelly would like to say a
couple of words no she was
thank you I'm honored that his legacy
still is alive today
and he would be proud to be here with
you all and my personal opinion he would
have been a Trump fan so tell me one
thing one thing so I see those tears
that means you think he will you miss
him and you love him right
was he actually a nice guy cuz he looked
tough Mike was just saying he was brutal
but he was a good guy right tough but
great thank you very much thanks Kelly
thank you all greatest sports story
could be number one
[Applause]
[Music]
so a lot of people a lot of these sports
experts sports riders have voted that as
the single greatest sporting event or
athletic achievement I think so yeah
number they put it number one certainly
tub top five in the history of our
country we have a lot of things that
we've done to break records we're going
to go over them but we've broken a lot
of records now but I want to thank that
great team for being with us very
inspirational this is a big day the
anniversary in my State of the Union
address I proudly declared that we are
in the midst of the great American
comeback and we're just getting started
after three years of ridiculous witch
hunts and partisan Democrat Crusades by
the way I think they're starting another
one did you see that I see these phonies
these that do-nothing Democrats they
said today that Putin wants to be sure
that Trump gets elected here we go
here we go again
did you see it a story aren't people
bored now does that include because a
couple of weeks ago crooked Hillary said
Chelsea gabart right Tulsi Gabbard and
right she was a Russian agent Tulsi and
also Stein from Jill Stein I don't know
Jill Stein I never met the woman she is
a Green Party candidate or was they said
she's an agent of Russia I don't know
her and I don't know Tulsi the only
thing I know about both of them is
they're not agent they are not agents of
Russia these people are sick that's
pencil-neck pencil-neck again
little pencil
now I just see it again I was told that
was happening I was told a week ago they
said you know they're trying to start a
rumor it's disinformation that's the
only thing they're good at they're not
good at anything else they get nothing
done do not think Democrats did dishes
that Putin wants to make sure I get
elected listen to this so doesn't he
want to see who the Democrats gonna be
wouldn't you rather have let's say
Bernie
wouldn't you rather that Bernie who
honeymooned in Moscow would never these
people are crazy that's all they think
about they don't think about the country
they don't think about jobs they don't
think about lowering your drug costs
infrastructure these people are crazy
trust me I like I like what we're doing
and I love this country
now and I campaigned on at the same time
we want to get along with Russia we want
to get along with China we want to get
along with all these countries who the
hell needs to have conflict but these
people are sick they are sick people the
radical left's attempts to poison our
democracy and overturn the last election
have totally ended in a big fat failure
and by the way you saw today single best
day I've ever had in the polls
and any poll that the fake news gives
you because the real numbers are higher
but any poll they give you is a fake but
Wisconsin the great state of Wisconsin I
was leading by many many many points
against every one of these characters
can you believe it we got a new one many
my Kennedy during the debate the other
day
minibike is a box bike here Mike boom
minibike he was a beauty what happened
to her he couldn't breathe what happened
Mike would like to know how about that
Pocahontas screaming at him she forgot
she forgot that she lied about her own
heritage she said she was an Indian
because she had high cheekbones that was
the only thing remember what I said I
have more Indian blood in me than she
has and I have none but I have done to
the best of my knowledge wouldn't mind
having some but I happen to have none
and she choked and she went out and got
a report done one 1024 you know what
that means that means probably I do have
more now why did he bring that up when
she was screaming at him why because he
was gasping for breath
I can't breathe he's got I can't breathe
lucky she's hitting me too hard
Pocahontas well she won that two Baker's
by could not respond
[Applause]
that's what they all said they all said
that that's footage I won they're all
shot it's not me that's saying it
figures
you fake dues people
[Applause]
now they all said it down who won the
debate Trump
you know what the way I look at it when
fake do CNN oops there goes the camera
off red light just went off see I can
tell every one of them I know them by
heart I know the operators I know the
cameraman they're okay they're all on
our side by the way they're screamed at
get that camera off I don't want to do
that get that camera off its gonna be a
jet all right I'm sorry president dick
but how about MS DNC they're worse than
she
and they're owned by people that really
are bad I think they're very bad for our
country the the owners of Comcast rotten
company bad for our country very bad
they try it you know they have all these
PR things to try and keep their image
nice and clean what they do on
television is so disgusting
I think in the old days you have
licenses for this stuff right they can
say whatever they want to say let's see
what happens over the next period of
time budget dishonest people Comcast
terrible company terrible people running
that company and you know what I had
Celebrity Apprentice I had the
apprentice on for 14 seasons 14 seasons
and they used to come to my office and
they would kiss my ass please sign
Vincent
please
please saw you know it's an interesting
story they came and we signed you know
who signed me Jeff Zucker it's one of
the only things he's done good in
broadcasting but I signed and NBC as you
know is owned by Comcast but I signed
and they figured the show would be a
total failure so they only sign before
once he said you know I was gonna have
it was go on and then the show goes
started at 10:00 went to 8:00 went to
7:00 went to 5:00 went to four went to
two it went to one I had the number one
show on all of television it was a
phenomenal phenomenal and the final
episode remember that with do you
remember that you remember the final we
had I don't know it was like one of the
biggest shows of the year was a
tremendous success but here I was I
signed with NBC and they didn't even
want to waste the ink on an option
usually they have an option for not you
know just like they didn't do it you
stupid people so they paid me very
little for the first season I think
$25,000 a show which is you know
considered like not good that's okay it
was fun I didn't know it's gonna be
success you know hey just like this was
successful
it's a recent because when I left then
Arnold Schwarzenegger and I like Arnold
said some very nice things yet that is
of not but the show did not exactly
succeed when I left but I had it on and
they wanted me to sign for more and I
said no I'm gonna run for president but
I'll never forget I looked at I didn't
know anything about this business and I
had an agent wonderful guy from William
Morris and he said sir I don't want you
to sign no business show has ever done
well on network television well what's
that business it's entertainment slash
sir I don't want you to sign sir
don't sign I said yeah okay but I have a
problem I shook the hand of somebody
I have to and Mark Burnett was great he
was my guy and but we shook hands so I
have to but I agreed you know I didn't
know that no business you know business
type show had ever succeeded on a
network television so he said I don't
want you to son sir break it I said I
can't break it can't break it anyway so
the show I said started at 10:00 went
and I went it became it was the number
one show all of a sudden and the agent
called me up and he said sir I remember
six in the morning I was in bed he said
sir the show just went to number one I'd
love to see you
because I think I'm entitled to more
money I said you didn't want me to do
the show well not really I mean I was
okay he said I'd really like more money
I said Jim I liked you very much
Jim you're fired get out anyway I had 14
great seasons over about 11 years
because in some it was so successful
they kept red they would have run it
remember when they did the three hours
the whole night was the apprentice I
said wait a minute
gone with the wind to mention the move
in the second time gone with the wind is
shorter they had the apprentice run for
three hours I said even I gets too long
you can't put it on for three you gotta
leave a little bit like I want to come
back next week but they had it on for
three weeks we did fantastically with it
Comcast did great NBC did great they
wanted me to sign for another three
years I said no I'm gonna run for
president and that was actually the time
when I knew I was going to run cuz you
know they were paying a lot of money and
whether you're rich or not it's still a
lot of money I don't care how rich yards
a lots of millions and millions of
dollars and I said no I'm gonna run for
president and I did that but from the
day I ran they went from being you know
wonderful they were nice they were you
know they were nice I guess if I didn't
do well with the show they wouldn't have
been nice because they weren't nice to
other people that fail you know people
that didn't have good ratings at
businesses are very simple business if
you have good ratings you can treat them
like garbage if you have bad ratings you
can say
sir I really respect you so much
get outta here get him out of my own
there very ruthless people but Comcast
is a rotten company they forgot totally
and they are worse than CNN I will tell
you that right now
Comcast is worse than CNN we should call
it Comcast cuz that's their beautiful
maiden name Comcast they're worse than
CNN I'll tell you something about CNN
Jake Tapper today he put out now I know
you don't like him I know who do who
likes him
who'da health care like I think his wife
likes him actually I really believe she
does but let me just tell you he put out
a couple of social media posts today
because I never call it tweet I called
it social media because it's much bigger
than tweet what we have dance Kavita the
great dance come you know we have one
five sides
we're number one on twitter we're number
one on facebook in the whole world in
the whole world
so it's powerful but Jake Tapper put out
some things basically saying I believe
it that's the way I read it that the new
Russian thing that started yesterday
that Putin wants to be sure the trumpets
give me a break
may have a break but Jake Tapper said it
ain't so
and if he did say that because they were
little complex you know they can turn
him around or when zuker sees him and
said why did you put that I want that
deleted and I want you to do a different
one but he did say that so I respect
that because it's another hoax story but
we're standing up for the defense of our
Constitution for our freedom and
democracy itself you know that
I gotta get that I love this shirt Bobby
I don't know he looks like a nice guy
can you please welcome up even if you
have about five come here come in come
on come here you gotta see this shirt
you got to see this shirt I love it
I'll get to order me one that I can ride
around come on come on up here he looks
safe he doesn't look like he's gonna
start a fistfight he's a good fan I
guess you got to see this shirt I love
it
is there any place that's more fun than
a trump rally right
how many rallies have you been to 80 he
said 80 rallies come up here club come
on come on what are these two guys these
guys are serious these are serious fans
right are you with him are you with them
are you with them you with them come on
come up man
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I just said how long have you two
been together I figured they'd say you
know what Merritt he met her at the
rally in Colorado can you believe do you
believe it man did he get lucky they
both got lucky right they both all right
it's cool no I just see there's so much
stuff out here it's genius actually
while the extreme left has been wasting
America's time with vile hoaxes we've
been killing terrorists creating jobs
raising wages and acting fair trade
deals securing our border lifting up
citizens of every race color religion
and Creed
as you heard we added another 225
thousand new jobs last month alone way
above anticipated schedule and that
makes seven million new jobs since the
election the number was supposed to be
under two million and we added seven
million and remember if I give you wrong
numbers the fake news is going to have
headlines Trump gave you wrong I mean
it's very tough I've got to be very
careful even if I give you wrong in the
wrong way they'll say it was wrong I
said yeah but it was wrong in the low
wage no that's still good either get it
be exactly very precise with these
characters the Democrats don't have to
be but we have to be we've destroyed the
ISIS territorial Caliphate 100 percent
we killed the founder and leader of Isis
al Baghdadi is dead al Baghdadi is dead
17 years they look for him 17 years
[Applause]
al baghdadi one of the first things I
did when I came in you know he's the
founder of Isis and when I came in three
years ago Isis was all over the place
and I said you got to knock it out we
knocked it out of Syria in Iraq and
other places we really doctored 100
percent remember I want to leave I said
all right we were at 96 percent then 98
then 99 percent I said let some of these
other countries do it wouldn't you say
right so what happened is I wanted to
leave and they said no no no we want a
hundred percent so we wait and stayed we
got a hundred percent that we moved them
all out of Seir except we did keep the
oil you notice that right we kept the
other sorry they said he left soldiers
in Syria I did to keep the oil of you
know mine
which is what we should have done in
Iraq too by the way I would have done
that and make it a lot of money with all
that oil but you remember that whole
thing that whole I said you got to find
out Baghdady
I've been saying that actually for two
years I had a lot of other things to do
the first year like fight off the
Democrats these crazy Democrats were
they're hoaxing were there helps us
think of it if they use their genius
because they are genius at that stuff
right they're really good they can take
nothing they can take a perfect phone
call made to the Ukrainian president who
said very specifically there was no
pressure he doesn't even know what's
going on and they can take this perfect
call thank goodness I had a transcriber
do you agree with it because the fake
whistleblower the fake whistleblower
said that the call was totally different
than what the call was so when I
released the call when I released the
transcripts they died they said ah we
got a problem they never thought I was
gonna do it but I had no choice I had to
because I had to show they're liars but
think of it they can take something like
that a perfect phone call or they'll
take just out of thin air they can make
something up and they ended up today
front page New York Times they used to
call it the 8th column that's the big
column on the right I don't know the
papers become so small I don't know if
they have an eighth column any
they used to have the eighth column was
a big deal right that was the big deal
today it's too narrow I think they're
probably after I'm gone they won't have
any columns
that's why eventually they're going to
support me eventually The Times and The
Washington Post which would be dead as a
doornail laughter I live and the CNN
it'll be an obsolete business the cable
business and Miss DNC will be out of
business
you know cable was supposed to be
obsolete and now they're doing the
highest numbers they've ever done if an
aeroplane goes down with 700 people they
don't cover it if it's not Trump related
they don't cover it it's got to be Trump
or Trump related so the plane goes down
and it's total devastation if the ship
goes down if the Titanic
if the Titanic equivalent went down they
wouldn't cover it unless I was on the
sucker
they wouldn't cover it the fake news
would not cover the equivalent of the
Titanic but you know what they're gonna
do before the election they're gonna say
we want to just say something we're
gonna endorse the president you know why
cuz they'll be out of business can you
imagine if they had to cover mini Mike
who I don't think I think he's gone but
you know what he'll spend another 500
million don't forget I spent 70 and I
won of my money in other words they said
and this was in the New York Times I
said it the other night in Colorado
I spent 70 mini mic so far spent almost
five hundred million dollars in order to
get embarrassed by Pocahontas
poka hot and she's mean isn't she did
you see that do you see the anger on her
face that nervous energy says like a
jumping up and down she's a mess but no
no she's mean right right
she that faces just you wanted to get
him she said I get him I want to see
those agreements I you open up those
agreements this poor guy probably signed
a hundred of them and and each one's a
disaster he said I don't want to open
those agreements nobody told me this was
gonna happen he said actually said
nobody told me
get me out of here you know after the
debate he went backstage fired a lot of
people he said how the hell did you get
me into this thing but anyway but
Pocahontas was really mean but she's
gonna be easy I hope it's her shit's not
gonna be her she made a little comeback
the other night because she took many
Mike to the cleaners but it's not gonna
be here
it can't be booted edge can't be out all
day Alfred he Newman ladies and
gentlemen introducing President
Alfred E Newman but see nobody knows cuz
you're all too young nobody knows who
Alfred it's bad Magazine they all said
no Howdy Doody see nobody knows who
Alfred aluminous only the real
aficionados they're the ones that they
love it but that's only 15 percent of
the crowd right am i right
better than Howdy Doody and how'd he do
but he's got a little you know he's got
to worry about his own city it's going
to hell so he's got to work because that
city's got a lot of problems I don't get
I don't get the whole thing but he's not
a bad debater I will say he's probably
the best up there Bernie is too
emotional he's screaming going crazy and
byte is angry by design everything's
anger gee ha ha and that's what happens
when you can't get the words out no it
does that's what happens right when you
can't get the words out you get angry
you get angry because you can't get the
words that might happen to me someday
can you imagine if that happened to me
man would I be a bad guy I'd be the
meanest man in history no but Biden is
very angry you know he gets angry and
angry and angry he's changed and then
you have that time yeah he said Tom
Steyer Tom sir mr. impeachment how did
that work out Tom thank you very much
for the great poll numbers between him
and nervous dancing
out of that workout this shmup spends
250 million dollars he ends up with 1/3
of a percent in Iowa but maybe that you
know that could be Ricker's they still
don't have any idea what he got maybe he
won Iowa they took it away from now but
he was substantially below it said all I
know it said 1% at an arrow left so he
spends 250 million tom Stein never heard
of this guy who is he where did he get
his money who is he you know he was in
the coal business did you know that this
guy this phony is a big environmentalism
he made his money a lot of it in the
coal business nobody knows that but he's
a fake remember when he walked up to
Bernie the other day hi Bernie
hi oh and he was having a fight with
Pocahontas right
his is the greatest Mark Burnett said
there's the greatest reality show in
history he said you can take the
apprentice and you could take Survivor
and you can take every other reality
show ever made multiply it times 10,000
and you still don't have what we have
and even the cast you did say this you
got the perfect president you got the
perfect first lady how about the first
one
you got the perfect kids the kids though
those beautiful kids my beautiful kids
they had such a great life before I did
this
sorry kids sorry my beautiful Ivanka she
had such a great life she had a company
that was selling shoes and everything
you could sell she just put her name on
it and she said daddy it doesn't matter
I want to come to Washington and help
people get jobs that's right and she
left the company and you know when you
leave a company all of a sudden it
doesn't do as well I wouldn't say that I
exactly helped talking about the wall
but she left the company came to
Washington and she said 500,000 jobs
that was ago and she did that in the
first month she actually did she's
gotten these great companies like
Walmart and many others Exxon she's
gotten them to take billions of people
she's now over 15 million jobs where
they train people and bring them into
the companies it's incredible 15 million
and she's smart you know she's got it
figured out but not most people can't
but she does but but all they do is give
them heat they work so hard and could
you imagine you take you take Biden son
can you imagine
[Applause]
you know I deal with all these big
companies in these great great countries
I think I could get my son's 25 board
ships for millions of dollars apiece my
kids would be back but you know what we
don't do any of that stuff we don't do
that so we don't do it the kid got three
million dollars eighty three thousand a
month and he didn't have a job until his
father became vice president and
speaking of vice presidents and speaking
of vice presidents okay and speaking
also of reality television because
there's the greatest show of all time
right
look at this look we told you what last
night little change there folks
we're going to move it up from 8 o'clock
in the evening till 12 o'clock in the
afternoon little change just a monitor
because I have to get back to Washington
or work I feel guilty this is too much
fun but speaking of vice presidents and
speaking of perfect vice presidents you
know if you become president the first
thing you have to do is choose a really
horrible horrible vice president so if
the idiots ever want to impeach you they
have to say I can impeach him look we
got look who we have I have the perfect
vice president I have the greatest in
the world I have the greatest vice
president
I got the great ones I said you know I
can't do that I picked a great guy he's
done a fantastic job he's been a great
vice president but it is so I could have
picked I'll give you names but I don't
want to do that because I don't want to
hurt anyone's feelings but there plenty
of them out there mostly out there and I
don't want to do that but Mike Pence has
been great but tell me is it perfect
casting the whole thing and this isn't
about casting this is about real life
but when Mark Burnett said to me the
other day he said the greatest reality
show of all times times a million and
it's that's exactly except for one thing
we work our asses off and we are doing
things like nobody has ever done before
right so we took out out Baghdady
and then we just took out two weeks ago
the world's top terrorists Qasem
Soleimani of Iran ending his evil reign
of terror forever he's the father of the
roadside bomb when you see our beautiful
people walking around with no legs
they're walking and trying to walk so
hard and they were really in rough shape
they have incredible the job the doctors
do it Walter Reid in some of these
hospitals and they get him to a point
where sometimes they really can they
walk around and but it's hard and they
lose legs and they lose arms that was
Salib a knee he's the father of the
right he loved the roadside bomb he
thought it was a great thing where is he
now Salim Ali and I'll tell you what you
know is happy about it the people of
Iran are happy and even the leaders of
Iran because the leaders of Iran were
afraid of him
okay and the fact is America is
respected again we're winning we're
winning all over we're winning in
Washington that Democrats keep losing
their minds that is why millions of
registered Democrat voters are leaving
their party to join our movement
they're joining the Republican Party
through we have a lot of look at the
energy in this room they're all fighting
they're all firing we're look we're
unified party the Republican Party has
never been unified like it is today
I mean I say I could say we're gonna go
over to the hill no we're gonna go over
to someplace and we're gonna do a rally
at eight o'clock tonight we'd have tens
of thousands of people there's never
been this you know Ronald Reagan was
great I thought he was a great guy great
president didn't like his policy and
Craig that's okay
trade but if he came to Las Vegas you
know they'd have a ballroom and it'd
have five hundred maybe a thousand
people what we're doing and this isn't
even I must say this I don't want to
tell you this this is not election
season because we're nine months away
you know election season is one year two
months away we're not even an election
season and we have more enthusiasm now
believe it or not then we had even
before the election in 2016
[Applause]
and so we have a great gentleman and
woman with us a friend of mine mr. and
mrs. sheldon adelson right over here
[Applause]
great great person two great people he's
got so much money he doesn't know what
the hell to do with it
[Applause]
he owns the Sands Hotel that's like one
of her smaller businesses Sheldon that's
like your small business right he is a
great guy she's an incredible where
she's a doctor and she studies addiction
and drugs drug addiction all sorts of
addictions and as she knows more about
that subject I think than anybody and
she works hard and she doesn't need it
he does not need the money that she
brings in okay he also happens to own
the paper
he owns the paper you own the paper in
town right they wanted like a couple of
hundred million dollars too much he said
give it to him it's peanuts what the
hell differences of it we want to thank
the Adelson's they've been incredible
fans and they love Israel they love
Israel I just saw him sitting there I
didn't know they were here I just see
him sitting there ah he's something the
chairman of the Nevada Republican Party
who's really been great he's been with
me for a long time and he's a very
committed man make America great again
you know this oh oh oh let's do a poll
quick just quick you know I'll never get
rid of maca because I'm superstitious
but you know we just hit an all-time
high with the stock market our
military's rebuild you just got the
greatest tax cuts in history the
greatest rate regulation cuts and all
this stuff so let me ask you this so
make America great again sort of doesn't
work what is
well so now we have Keep America greater
we have the new hat it's higher stiff
it's like a billboard right I call it
the billboard it's a billboard so let's
go
just that occurs I am very surprised by
it we're gonna keep them both but I just
curious if we did go to one make America
great again Keep America great
I would have said thats impossible make
America great again is the greatest
phrase a lot of people again make news I
think we'll agree to it it's the
greatest phrase ever used in politics
it's the greatest friends now who has
the greatest phrase ever used in the
history of politics and say oh let's go
with the new phrase right but we're
going to keep so we have to keep Magda
but now we have CAG now we have Kat so
we have them both I just don't have the
courage to get rid of the water would be
too disrespectful too disrespectful but
Michael McDonald I want to thank you and
the members of the Nevada Republican
Central Committee you're all here the
great people and a man came here he
loves us he's been with us Rick Harrison
of the world famous Gold & Silver Pawn
Shop
Rick Harrison you better win Michael
otherwise that's the less time I'm
introducing you like that hey you were
up by here we're doing nicely I hear
we're doing great and by the way the
Union I have a lot of respect for that
Union you know less time I had to strike
in my building during the election it's
the only reason we would have won this
state I'm like brilliantly to save three
cents I could have settled the strike
before the election I wanted to save two
dollars total that was a brilliant move
and then we had some guy running guy
named Hecht and he wasn't too good he
didn't do too good but we almost won
this day despite I had a big strike at
thousands and thousands of Union guys
they had it you know look they wanted
you know one to show us but I think that
the unions are really with us and the
unions have been with us the Teamsters
so many of the union's because I'm for
the working man and woman whether you're
union or non-union
some states are all Union sub states or
no Union but we get them all and I think
we're gonna have tremendous success and
you know a lot of the Democrats are
going to ruin the health care programs
that these unions have the unions have
worked hard on health care and they're
going to ruin them they're going to take
away a hunt well with it you can lose a
hundred and eighty million people off of
great private health care so we'll see
what happens but a lot of the Democrats
want to do that they think it's
wonderful but together we're building
the world's most prosperous economy and
the most inclusive society that's true
since my election over 125,000 new jobs
have been created right here in Nevada
including over 40,000 new Nevada
manufacturing and construction jobs a
30% increase the national unemployment
rate is the lowest in over half a
century and soon we're gonna have so
we're gonna have that be a historic
number like so many of the others the
average unemployment rate for my
administration this is the coolest of
them all is the lowest for any United
States president in recorded history
that's pretty good that's pretty good
when I'm going to debate this saying
we're going to do this so wick I said
listener we have the best unemployment
numbers in the history of our country
african-american unemployment hispanic
american hispanic we got a lot of
Hispanic I love Hispanic who is this
what is his Hispanic yeah we're doing
great well we should be doing great you
have the lowest ever recorded lowest
unemployment rates ever recorded Asian
Americans likewise the lowest ever
recorded the unemployment rate for women
reached the lowest rate in 71 years
african-american youth unemployment has
reached an all-time historic low people
I love people I might have helped more
than anybody because of choice said
accountability the veterans unemployment
rate dropped to the lowest record
employment lowest in history the
unemployment rate for disabled Americans
has reached an all-time historic low and
you got to remember they're back to
their check in every word that got over
oh he's right he's right he's right
I can't say it because I got all these
maniacs back there they're trying to
fight you know he put the comma in the
wrong place he didn't make that word
plural therefore he lied he lied I got
to be very accurate because all these
numbers they check them out as they
check up they're in there check it out
check on the african-american
unemployment place please tell me please
tell me it's not historic these people
among the most dishonest human beings on
earth not all of them not all of them
workers without a high school diploma we
have millions of people they didn't go
through high school they left they had
problems good problems bad problems
families where they don't have the money
they didn't get a high school diploma
they've achieved the lowest unemployment
rate ever recorded in the history of the
United States
there's important groups of people half
a million more Hispanic Americans now
own a home now Hispanic have done so
good and by the way you know who
understands the border because we are
building that wall like crazy you know
who understands remember they also know
if you build the wall you lose the
Hispanic vote I said I got to do what's
right you know who understands the
border better than anybody you know who
understands crime at the border
better than anybody the Hispanics
understand it and they don't want to be
working and have people come and take
their job have people come in where they
can't pay for their house have people
come in who are very very bad people you
have some very bad people you have
murderers and rapists and we have said
all sorts of records at the border but
we're up to 122 miles of wall and it is
true the people that understand it the
best are Hispanic so thank you and I
make our country safe that I make our
country safe we've lifted ten million
people off of welfare median household
income is now the highest ever recorded
in our country think of that President
Bush I say it all the time
President Bush eight years four hundred
and fifty dollars
President Barack Hussein Obama
eight years eight years nine hundred and
seventy-five dollars president Donald
John Trump three years it's actually
less when they did the numbers three
years including the big tax cuts that we
got you and the regulation cuts three
years so you had four fifty nine hundred
and seventy-five dollars it's eight and
eight now we're down to three years
little less three years ten thousand
dollars per family a year ten thousand a
year our historic regulatory reduction
campaign is restoring American liberty
and ending the tyranny of federal
bureaucrats I deal with them they're not
good it's called the swamp we've ended
the war in American energy lowering
utility bills reducing prices at the
pump reducing your prices part of that
number is all of the money that we save
at the pump and on electric I also
recently took action on an issue Nevada
has been dealing with for over 30 years
Yucca Mountain you know you come on my
budget stops funding for the licensing
of waste storage at Yucca Mountain so
that we can focus on positive solutions
and for much better reasons and
alternatives why should you have nuclear
waste in your backyard why should you
have nuclear waste in your backyard I
won't say which countries but you know
what other countries there I will not
say which one they put it on her ship
they floated out into the middle of the
ocean they find a nice deep spot they
dump it that's the end of it but we
would never do that for environmental
reasons we are reversing decades or
Yucca Mountain you're okay please okay
just relax
you have somebody Sheldon do you have
somebody at your newspaper back there
who can write Yucca Mountain please
he'll call up y'all come out is okay
that's the end of that that's the end of
that so Yucca Mountain you're in great
shape maybe they could finally report it
properly but we're reversing decades of
calamitous trade policies for years
Washington politicians took money from
lobbyists global corporations and
corrupt special interest to ship our
jobs and factories and all of this stuff
and all of this wealth they stole our
wealth they shipped it overseas and to
other countries America lost one in four
manufacturing jobs following the twin
disasters of NAFTA and China's entrance
into the WTO the World Trade
Organization probably an even worse deal
for us than NAFTA that's possible but
under my administration the great
betrayal of America is over America is
no longer for sale
last month we ended the NAFTA
catastrophe and I signed the brand-new
US Mexico Canada agreement u.s. MCA see
we played the song YMCA cuz that's the
only way you're about just think of the
song YMCA think of the song and you
remember that us MCA is a gigantic
victory for farmers ranchers and
manufacturers all across the great state
of Nevada I also took the strongest ever
action to confront China's massive theft
of American jobs our strategy worked
last month we signed a groundbreaking
trade agreement probably the biggest
agreement of any kind ever signed with
China that will defend our workers
protect our intellectual property and
boost American exports by a lot China
will be buying two hundred and fifty
billion dollars worth of goods from us
now and fifty billion from our farmers
my guys wanted 16 I said make it 50 my
guys wanted 16 they got China up to 20 I
said nope gotta make it 50 then I said
to China got a billion and I have people
what difference does it make they said
you're right 50 billion I don't think
our farmers can produce that much but
we're gonna soon find out they're going
to buy very large tractors after years
of building up other countries we are
finally rebuilding our country
we are finally putting America first or
no issue of Washington Democrats more
thoroughly sold out the American people
than the issue of immigration before I
came into office the far left policy of
open borders allowed deadly drugs to
flow freely into our country poisoning
our children including right here in a
very very big way the great state of
Nevada Washington Democrats put the
needs of illegal immigrants before the
well-being of American citizens you know
that you've been complaining about for a
long time so one of the reasons you
voted for Trump they want to let anyone
from around the world simply walk across
the border and then they want to give
them a lifetime of free welfare of
health care of lots of other things
including education all paid for by the
taxpayers of the United States
illegal immigration costs Nevada
taxpayers think of it more than 1.6
billion dollars every year over $1,500
per household for the amount of money
Washington Democrats want to spend
supporting illegal immigrants we could
rebuild every city
all of these distressed areas in the
United States throughout our country the
money we spend it's not even thinkable
and don't forget when we say come like
in California the clown
he says come come we'll give you free
health care people that weren't even
thinking about coming that's why we have
caravans of people that were turning
back Mexico's been great by the way they
gave us twenty seven thousand soldiers
on our board
but when a governor nice guy actually is
a nice guy we just got to explain the
facts of life he's a nice guy
Oh doctor please doctor doctor in the
house please medic oh please a doctor
thank you thank you take your time
thank you time we got plenty of time
[Applause]
take your time please you know a lot of
these people have been here for three
days it's a lot those front row people
are tough
[Applause]
[Music]
take your time doc take your time
[Applause]
thank you everybody thank you doctor
thank you
let's sir they get here so they stand
and sit and sometimes days early in
Colorado they're there three four days
early it's tough it's tough and we work
it and make sure that you have
everything you want number one we cover
the facts and number two we want to have
a good time because we have to have a
good time you have to have a good time
but things like that happen happen a lot
because after two three days it's not
easy and these are strong people I'm not
going to fight any of them okay now our
amazing people thank you very much thank
you
under my administration we're finally
taking care of our own citizens first
including millions and millions of legal
immigrants who follow our laws pay their
taxes lift up our society and are
entitled to a government that protects
their families and protects their
communities every day Democrats open
border policies are harming and killing
innocent people you know what's
happening you know what's going on in
this region alone last year ice officers
and they're Patriots they're strong
tough Patriots if we didn't have them
they'd remove thousands and thousands of
ms-13 gang members a year and plenty of
others who else is going to do it
I saw officers arrested over 5000
criminal aliens charged or convicted of
dangerous offenses including robbery
rape and even murder many murders in
western Nevada an illegal alien was
charged with robbing and brutally
executing four victims last year right
here in Las Vegas three ms-13 gang
members abducted a man tied him up with
his shoelaces shot him repeatedly and
hacked him to death with a machete you
know exactly what I'm talking
about it's right here in your place in
Las Vegas right here they hacked him to
death tied up and hacked him to death
yet left-wing politicians oppose all
detention of illegal aliens even
convicted criminals and murderers and
they support deadly sanctuary cities
[Applause]
you know I say this all the time and I
just had a hell I mean where are they
coming from I don't get it
right seriously I don't get it Thanks
your city's imperil American lives by
releasing dangerous criminal aliens
directly into your communities if you
want to shut down sanctuary cities if
you want to protect your family and your
loved ones you must vote Republican in
2020 and you have some great ones here
Michael thanks to our tireless efforts
to secure the border we have reduced
illegal border crossings eight straight
months in a row and as the wall gets
longer it gets easier and easier
remember when the Democrats were saying
you don't need a wall you know two
things that never change right all these
computers they said use drones oh great
will fly level drones watch the people
pour in by the thousands well that's
great use drones you know before I came
along they all wanted a wall they just
did not a build it bad don't blue they
had no clue they had no true they had
the money that they had no they actually
gave the money back but they had no
clothes but as soon as I came in and I
said wall wall wall they went against
and I made a terrible terrible mistake
you know they were saying never admit
mistakes I do but I'll admit a mistake
now I should have said we will never
ever under any circumstances build a
wall they would have given me so much
money for a wall you up wall they would
have forced me to build it I made a
terrible mistake right terrible is that
so if it ever happens again which it
won't this wall is one of a kind
will say we will not build the wall and
they'll say we demand that you build the
wall and it would have been so easy
illegal crossings are down 75% since
last spring and we have ended catch and
release horrible
we catch him you notice sir
they come over could be a killer murder
rapist they come over we can't do
anything we have to be politically
correct we catch them we then say what's
your address they don't know they don't
even know their country in many cases
where do you come from we don't know and
they mean it but some are very serious
criminals so we catch them we take
whatever they can take which is nothing
and then we had to release them in our
country we can't bring them back and
then we have a system of judges
thousands of judges all over the place
you got to be like Perry Mason and
everybody every illegal that comes in
they have the lawyers you know the
lawyers meet them they get fees they get
paid fees but we'll break in the system
no more catch and release you think that
was easy and the big thing is that 30
foot and this wall is built exactly to
the specifications of Border Patrol
totally and Border Patrol has seized the
largest amount just recently of deadly
narcotics ever recorded the largest
about we've deported record numbers of
gang members we've done more to secure
the border than any Administration in
history we are as I said building the
wall faster than ever faster and bigger
than anyone thought possible they can't
believe we're getting it done we'll have
over 500 miles of wall built sometime
next year 500 by Washington Democrats
have never been more extreme than they
are right now
132 congressional Democrats have now
signed up for Bernie Sanders takeover of
health care that would strip one hundred
and
80 million Americans many of them in
this room of their private coverage
remember President Obama remember he
said you can keep your doctor you can
keep your plan 28 times he lied so we
should impeach him we should have
picture we're gonna pizza we'll do it
belated impeachment we're gonna do it a
belated April 28 times you can keep your
doctor right remember you could keep
your doctor you could get other
unfortunately when they found out you
can't keep your doctor he said I was
just kidding now we should impeach him
we'll do a belated impeachment fake news
you have it so you have to be very
careful when you say impeach him because
you know what they do they go back and
they write they write President Trump
said that Obama should be funny he's not
in office and so therefore they can't be
he doesn't know what he's talking about
because he's not in office so therefore
they can't so you have to be very
careful that's why I used the word
belated impeachment belated meaning I'm
just kidding okay they do it all the
time they had it the other there said
bring back on with the wind right I said
the movie I said a little bit up here
but I said the movie the other day in
Colorado I guess I said South Korean
movie would you know they said ladies
and gentlemen the winner of the Academy
Award is and as a rule a movie made in
South Korea I said what's this all about
and I deal with them they like me we're
helping them a lot they're killing us on
trade you know they beat us in trade and
then they win the Academy Award for a
freaking movie but we redid that trade
deal but the other day they got me on
this one too I said whatever happened to
Gone with the Wind
that beautiful movie Vivien Leigh Clark
Gable right whatever happened
bring back on with the wind and some of
them wrote he doesn't know that that
movie was made like in 1936
so anybody sitting Jesus fake news it is
fact is they're fakers
but now anybody sitting there reading
they're saying and Trump can't be that
smart you know he said bring back on
with the wind that's it all movie yeah
it's an old classic bring back
what I say is make great movies you know
not this computerized crap
computerized garbage and I was never a
fan of Brad Pitt I will tell you
no I thought he was a stiff he was like
a stiff it's like a boring guy all of a
sudden he wins the Academy well it's a
fitting their ratings aren't so good in
the academy award you know when that's
up when they started attacking us their
ratings went right down the tubes you
know I told somebody the evening
newscast you know they're terrible for
conservative people and that they're
crooked they're absolutely dishonest I
said to one of the big broadcasters I'm
friendly with them I said you know if
you ever did a conservative newscast
instead of have you know you got ABC is
terrible terrible NBC is just absolutely
atrocious and they do badly you know not
a lot of people are watching they used
to where we had the late great Walter
Cronkite and these legends right but ABC
is terrible and NBC is terrible and CBS
is terrible they're all the same and I
said you know your ratings think if you
would do a newscast that's conservative
I'd get them a host I could recommend
guys right now right I'd get up my house
we'll call up
we'll call up don't take Sean Hannity
away from us please don't take our show
that's my problem I don't want to take
away any of our people you get a Pete
Haig set you get it Jess you orders you
get I mean I could name so many of it
right and you put them on that broadcast
that ratings would go up fivefold but
they don't know that I don't know this
stupid they're stupid
there's stupid their ratings would go
through the roof but they would rather
have a failed broadcast that nobody
watches then put on a conservative
person and lift the ratings five times
they would rather have a fail just like
they were hoping seven months ago you
know we had a little skid and they were
hoping the market would crash because
they would rather lose their money or
big parts of it and have a really
horrible market on the basis that we not
may we could not be elected on November
third
this is how evil that's this is now
crazy there they've gone crazy I guess
you call it Trump derangement syndrome
but if they ever did a conservative
broadcast meaning very fair very honest
but if it's almost like what I say that
it's almost like do a fair broadcast
just let's say our burgers
that thing would be the hottest show but
they don't realize it and if they do
they probably wouldn't do it anyway
because they don't want to go away from
what they're doing which is crazy
because it is they are doing very poorly
while the social and socialist Democrats
are trying to destroy American health
care in your Social Security they're
putting it at risk my administration is
protecting your Social Security member
they said four years ago in the debates
and you had this crazy woman I mean I
hate to mention her name I did it you
know yesterday through all the runs
hater
she's a zero zero it's got zero
television personality zero a be
Stoddard whoever that is
she said Donald Trump lost all of his
debates I want every debate and maybe I
don't know baby one somebody but I want
with tremendous enough he said you
always would we try I'll tell you that
and we win enough but this crazy woman
who's got zero going zero
she's a Donald Trump losses debates that
he won you know she was talking about
how badly Benny Mike did so she said
well Donald Trump no I won every single
debate
I want him against crooked Hillary I
want them in the primaries like fifteen
or sixteen debates and for some reason
you know sometimes you do say does not a
big deal nobody watches her nobody cares
nobody even knows who she is I just made
her famous right she's nothing she's
nothing she's got no talent got nothing
it's probably got a little Drive that's
how she keeps getting on television or
other people don't have her drive but
you know what I said that's really
unfair so I took out the polls Time
magazine Drudge good guy Drudge Drudge
took out a lot of different things and
we put up the Drudge poll the Time
magazine and many others and some of
them had me down like at 91% and then
they'd have many people
I can't rush out because many of those
people are now great friends of mine
some of them are great Republican
senators I'm not going to show results
but I'm holding it up just quickly
glancing I caught a glancing blow but we
won the debates and I have this fake
news person saying Donald Trump did very
poorly in the debates I want every
debate easily I never did it before
remember my first question I said Rosie
O'Donnell it was one of my best answers
Rosie O'Donnell who violated the
campaign finance laws as badly as
anybody I've ever seen and nothing
happens to her
right and yet an ish by violate that we
made a little mistake and they want to
destroy him
so we pardoned him by the way he made a
mistake Rosie O'Donnell that was a
massive violation of the campaign
finance laws but dinesh kanesha says
they wanted to put him in jail I don't
know I think he might have even gone to
jail for a period of time for doing
something that was really very
understandable Rosie O'Donnell five
times what she did is incredible
nothing happens and then she gets on and
says what a bad guy are you I'm not a
bad guy but it's really a disgrace you
know it's a disgrace I'm glad they
didn't do anything with her frankly
because you don't want to do for
something like that but you know what
how do they take we have two sets of
justice in this country it's no good
it's so good it's no good you know you
know the thing we're working on right
now we're trying to get fairness for a
certain person who's been treated very
unfairly
a man who a man who had a juror who was
a radical anti-trump person and she
didn't say that when she went up there
and she became the foreperson of the
jury and she did terrible things and
said terrible things and you know how
they caught her when he was convicted
and then a statement was made she
started jumping up and down screaming
yes yes and started telling everybody
how could they said whatever wasn't she
just a juror the woman was totally
biased how do you do this
so I fight look I fight a lot of times
it's not worth it but I gotta fight for
fairness I gotta fight
gotta fight for Thanos very unfair
system I guess it's called the swamp I
just you know when I said drained the
swamp was a nice phrase I never liked
the phrase you know when I was
campaigning somehow the phrase came up I
think we have a phrase drain the swamp I
said I don't like it that's too hokey
but one day I was in a big arena 25,000
people packed before the election and I
said and we will drain the swamp the
place went crazy I said wow you never
know you never know Frank Sinatra said
his best song I won't tell you which one
because I wrote it for you but his best
song is the song that he thought would
never make it the song that he liked at
least but he said that's the one that
was the most successful that the people
like you never know
so I said drain the swamp and the people
went crazy I said whoa I said let's try
that again and the next time I did it
again and again and again I only didn't
know how disgusting and dirty the swamp
is and a lot of the media is a big part
of the swamp
so my administration is protecting your
Social Security your Medicare and is
fighting to give you great health care
we're defending your right to keep your
doctor and your plan we're defending
that right you're gonna have that right
back we're going to cancel that
Obamacare if we could win the case and
we're going to give you great health
care and we're making health care better
and much cheaper while premiums more
than doubled in the last five years
before I took office we're managing it
very well we got rid of the individual
mandate by far the most unpopular thing
where you had to pay a lot of money for
the privilege of not having to pay for
bad health care right we got rid of it
and it was upheld in the Supreme Court
what we did every we get sued everything
we do if we move if we take ten steps
right or left we get sued and we're now
offering plans that are up to sixty
percent less expensive we're gonna make
health care a big part of this campaign
we're protecting people with
pre-existing conditions that we always
will that's why if we are successful you
know we're in the Supreme Court to try
and get rid of this the caucus it's a
caucus known as Obamacare but we're
running it much better than they did
remember when they had this was the
greatest the five billion dollar website
five billion was supposed to cost five
million I have a son at home he's 13
he's a genius with computers hi dad
what's up there dad get out of here hey
listen I'm the President of the United
States better go talk to you dad come on
down can't you see I'm playing with my
computer the guy talks to me he's
working with his computer these guys are
genius you know they grow up with it's
like walking right but he's looking at
me I could have given him their health
care so he would have done it for
nothing and it would have been better
than what they have
come on dad I'm busy then what do you
want what do you want dead bear
whoa baron whoa wow they're gonna like
he's gonna like them he's a he's a good
boy he's a tall boy I'll tell you that
just turned 13 he's up to him said hi
baron how you doing now he's good but
they're great with the computers and
they spent five billion okay it was
gonna cost 50 it was good of course five
it was gonna cost fifty there was gonna
what was the final number five hundred
the number was so a number that they
spent five billion dollars right it
ended up still doesn't work they spent
five billion dollars right and they
spent five hundred billion dollars on
all of the problems it caused and we've
really straightened it out but it's
still lousy health care Obamacare and
it's really not Obamacare anymore
because when you get rid of the
individual mandate it's no longer
Obamacare but we're going to terminate
it we're going to give you your
pre-existing a hundred other wise I
won't do it we're going to give you
brand-new pre-existing and we're going
to have a great health care that's much
less expensive
and we're fighting to stop surprise
medical ability and Berens going to be
very happy that I signed an executive
order imposing price transparency
because when providers are required to
show their prices those same prices fall
very fast you know the man that does
this very professionally is great into
the health care business and you have to
be careful when you say it but you know
it was just a very strong stay but he
said sir price transparency in hospitals
where you can bid it out and you can
look at the prices right now you can't
see if you go to a house but they won't
even tell you how much it's gonna cost
they operate and then they'll give you a
bill and you'll say oh my I had no idea
could be they take blood we have one
person blood $39 another place the exact
same thing $2,500 take blood a blood
test
once $39 once $2,500 the same test maybe
the $39 test is better who the hell
knows but it's crazy price transparency
and he looked at me goes and he's a real
pro one of the top in the country said
sir and nobody wanted to do it because
it's a little bit controversial and a
lot of the drug companies don't exactly
love it the hospitals don't love it but
I got to do what's right for the people
I don't care I'm not
but he looked at me he said and this is
why I did it it was one phrase you know
do you ever do were you not gonna do
something then somebody hits you with a
perfect phrase he said sir price
transparency is bigger than healthcare I
said what do you mean by that he said
you will see numbers that far outweigh
healthcare hospitals doctors he said
you'll be able to price out everything
you'll be able to see costs he said
price transparency you know people have
you've heard about this for 15-20 years
no president has the guts to do and it
probably means I won't get campaign
contributions from certain people but
I'm not going to get them anyway what
the hell difference does it make I don't
wanna I don't want I got to do what's
right you know we're here for a short
period of time even if it's a long
period it's still a short period and we
got to do so price transparency is a big
deal he said it's bigger than health
care think of that bigger than health
care so let's see what happens but
that'll kick in unfortunately that kicks
in after the election because we're
going through the final stages we're
going through a statutory process
unfortunately so think of it we're gonna
win but let's see
let's say the fake news can give me
enough phony stories enough bad stuff
that we don't make it the new president
will get all the credit for price
transparency and he won't even know what
the hell it is and I took the heat is
that something but we're gonna win we
gotta win for that reason alone we've
approved a record number of affordable
new generic drugs which are just as good
as the name-brand drugs but a fraction
of the cost and that was another one
tremendous political pressure to think
of it you own Bayer Aspirin you own all
these name name-brand drugs they're
making so much money and then a guy
comes along said I want to make twenty
forms of aspirin they're exactly the
same exactly but they don't have a big
name on it exactly is good I don't say
better I don't say worse they're exactly
the same
you know people still they want to go
out and buy the name you know I do I do
you know because it's just because we're
stupid no it's true
they're exactly the same we're approving
so many of the generic drugs a record
number nobody's ever approved so much
the drug companies hated hate it's never
happened like what we're doing we also
took down the trial periods from 12
years down to five or six years because
was they'd have a new drug the thing was
obsolete by the time it got approved
we've passed a really spectacular thing
that they've been trying to get for 40
some-odd years right to try so you don't
have to now go if you get hopefully
nobody in this room has those kind of
problem right to try and so now you go
and you sign a waiver and you get
everything and it's great if you're
terminally ill if you're very very sick
you're not gonna make it and you know
why they didn't do it they wouldn't
approve it because they didn't want to
be sued and they said no this could be
dangerous they said the people are
terminally ill they're gonna die let him
use the experimental drugs don't wait
because they have another four or five
years before they can come onto the
market and it turned out we are having
such unbelievable results and you know
what else some of those drug companies
are now like it if they fought me like
crazy because it's really sure
if it works there it's really showing
that it works it's pretty amazing right
to try I hope you don't have to use it
we're combating the opioid epidemic drug
overdose deaths have declined for the
first time in nearly 31 years and I've
launched doing.and and this is really
something brand new initiatives
combating kidney disease and combating
Alzheimer's disease we've made a lot of
progress we've made a lot of progress
Sheldon and we're pursuing new advances
in the neonatal research to care for
America's youngest patients our babies
and breaking all records in so doing all
of the radical Democrats and the
presidential debates have declared their
unlimited support for extremely term
abortion ripping babies straight from
the mother's womb right up until the
very moment of birth this is why in my
State of the Union address did you like
it but that's a different kind of
address you know we can go lots of
different ways
presidential not presidential I was
presidential totally yet about three
people standing here but I asked
Congress to prohibit late term abortion
of babies because Republicans believe
that every child is a sacred gift from
God
the Democrat Party is the party of high
taxes high crime open borders late term
abortion socialism blatant corruption
and the total obliteration of your very
very important Second Amendment the
Republican Party is the party of the
American worker the American family the
American Dream and the late great
Abraham Lincoln which everybody forgot
Republicans are fighting for citizens
from every background every community
and every single walk of life we are the
party of boundless optimism excitement
energy and enthusiasm we are wealthy
right
we are dually enthusiastic
[Applause]
you know how many of these have done in
the last four days people say where the
hell do you get your energy I say well
the truth is I like what I do and if we
weren't getting the results I wouldn't
like it
if we weren't getting the results if I
didn't see the results I wouldn't like
it at all we're welcoming Americans of
all parties and political persuasions to
join our incredible movement to make
America great again we're a very big
party we are the party of big ideas for
the future Republicans are fighting for
school choice because no parent should
ever be forced to send their child to a
failing government school I passed
criminal justice reform to give former
prisoners a second chance at life was
never going to happen we got it done
this could not have been done by anyone
but the Republican Party and ourselves
you know the Democrats have tried for
years they couldn't get it done we got
it done two appalled the rule of law we
are confirmed and this is something they
say most important thing you can do
judges I say most important thing is
defense second is judges a record number
of 217 federal judges who will interpret
the Constitution as written and we have
appointed two great new Supreme Court
justices Neal Gorsuch and Brett
Kavanaugh
I recognized Israel's true capital and
opened the American Embassy in Jerusalem
and we recognized Israeli sovereignty
over the Golan Heights
we have invested 2.2 trillion dollars to
rebuild the United States military
including more than 130 million dollars
for Nellis Air Force Base right here and
we just created the sixth branch of the
American armed forces the space for 72
years 72 years the Air Force was 72
years ago we just did a branch it's a
big deal isn't it think of it a branch
the Army Air Force think of it we did a
branch for years you watched as your
politicians apologize for America now
you have a president who is standing up
for America and we are standing up for
the people of Nevada at stake in our
present battle is the survival of our
nation if you want your children to
inherit the blessings that generations
of Americans have fought and died for to
secure then we must devote everything we
have toward victory in November of 2020
November 3rd November 3rd
only this way can we save the America we
love and drain the Washington swamp once
and for all with your help we will lift
millions more of our citizens from
welfare-to-work dependence to
independence and poverty to prosperity
together we will elect a Republican
Congress to create a fair safe sane and
lawful system of immigration we will
continue to enact new trade deals that
result in more products proudly stamped
with that very beautiful phrase made in
the USA we will achieve new
breakthroughs in science and medicine
finding new cures for childhood cancer
and ending the AIDS epidemic within nine
years in America and we will land the
first woman on the moon and become the
first station of the world to plant its
flag on Mars we will defend privacy free
speech religious liberty and the right
to keep and bear arms
and that is under siege in case you
haven't noticed you know your second
Amendment is under siege just don't
worry long as I'm here they're not
touching it above all we will never stop
fighting for this so true but we will
never stop fighting for the sacred
values that bind us together as one
America we support protect and defend
the Constitution of the United States we
stand with the incredible heroes and
they are heroes we love them of law
enforcement we believe in the dignity of
work and the sanctity of life we believe
that faith and family not government
bureaucracy are the true American Way we
believe that children should be taught
to love our country honor our history
and to always respect our great American
flag
and we live by the words of our national
motto In God We Trust from Carson City
to Reno to right here in Las Vegas we
stand on the shoulders of red-blooded
American patriots who poured out their
heart sweat and soul to secure our
Liberty and to defend our break
beautiful lovely freedom freedom freedom
freedom Nevada was founded by pioneers
and prospectors miners and Cowboys who
tamed the frontier raised the mighty
Hoover Dam at sub Beauty transformed the
barren desert into his shining Oasis lit
up the lights of the Las Vegas Strip and
helped to make this the greatest nation
ever to exist on the face of the earth
and we are making it greater than ever
before
proud citizens like you helped build
this country and together we are taking
back our country we are returning power
to you the American people with your
help your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on working we are going to
keep on fighting and we are going to
keep on winning winning winning we are
one movement one people one family and
one glorious nation under God America is
thriving like never before and ladies
and gentlemen of Nevada the best is yet
to come
together we will make America wealthy
again we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again we will
make America safe again and we will make
America great again thank you very much
everybody thank you thank you Nevada
Thank You Las Vegas we love Las Vegas
thank everybody thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I always get what you want
good evening
[Music]